direkt nach dem urknall gab es im kosmos
nur die elemente wasserstoff helium und
lithium die meisten aller elemente
entstanden dann erst durch die
kernfusion im inneren von sternen jetzt
ist einem internationalen forschungsteam
eine echte premiere gelungen die
fachleute konnten nämlich durch
spektralanalysen nachweisen dass schwere
elemente wie zum beispiel gold bei
neutronenstern kollision erzeugt werden
das ist ein echter durchbruch für die
astrophysik und die war erst durch die
neue methode der gravitationswellen
astronomie möglichst nicht um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
woher stammen schwerer elemente wie uran
blei oder gold oder anders gefragt bei
welchen prozess entstehen sie das ist
ein rätsel dass der fachwelt bis heute
schlaflose nächte bereitete klar ist
dagegen schon bank urknall wurden
leichte elemente wie wasserstoff und
helium erzeugt die etwas schwereren
elemente bis hin zum eisen entstanden
dann nach den bisherigen erkenntnissen
bei kern fusionen im inneren der sterne
doch jetzt endlich ist auch dass physik
puzzle um die entstehung der schweren
elemente gelöst denn ein internationales
astronomenteam konnte quasi die element
schmiedet des kosmos aufspüren doch von
vorne und zurück zu einer
sensationsmeldung des jahres 2017
damals gelang der erste nachweis einer
neutronenstern kollision und zwar mit
hilfe der detektoren lego und büro also
dieser gravitationswellen detektoren
diese registrierten die entsprechenden
gravitationswellen und auch die strahlen
ausbrüche konnten durch teleskope
aufgezeichnet werden
auch im sichtbaren nicht offenbarte sich
dieses ergebnis es gab eine sogenannte
kilo nova radioaktive prozesse führen zu
einem nachleuchten das zunächst immer
heller wird und dann innerhalb einiger
tage wieder abschwächt diese kosmische
kollision konnte am 17 august 2017
beobachtet werden und zwar in der
galaxie ngc 493 die rund 130 millionen
lichtjahre entfernt liegt die spektren
wurden dann eingehend analysiert doch
zunächst war weiter unklar wie wir uns
die reaktionsprodukte vorzustellen haben
deswegen erfolgte eine weitere
untersuchung bei der auch fachleute des
max planck instituts für astronomie
dabei waren
spektren wurde dann schließlich die
signatur das element strontium
aufgespürt dieses schwere element wurde
also bei der explosionsartigen
verschmelzung der beiden neutronensterne
gebildet in der fachsprache ist vom
sogenannten schnellen neutronen
einfangen oder auch r prozesse rede
wobei das r für rapid also schnell steht
genau das haben forschende auch schon
aufgrund theoretischer überlegungen
vermutet die schweren atome entstehen
also bei einem prozess bei dem freien
neutronen an bereits bestehende
bausteine angelagert werden dazu dass
watson aus kopenhagen der an der studie
beteiligt war
durch die neue analyse der im jahr 2017
gewonnenen daten des ereignisses haben
wir die signatur eines schweren elements
in diesem feuerball identifiziert damit
haben wir bewiesen dass die kollision
von neutronensternen dieses element im
universum erzeugt um solche schweren
elemente wie strontium zu erzeugen ist
also nicht nur extrem viel hitze
notwendig sondern auch viele freie
neutronen mit denen die atome
bombardiert werden bei der
neutronenstern kollision im jahr 2017
entstand eine blase die sich mit bis zu
30 prozent der lichtgeschwindigkeit
ausdehnt ungefähr fünf erdmassen der
expandierenden hülle entsprachen dabei
dem anteil des neu gebildeten strontium
und das ganze läuft unwahrscheinlich
schnell ab dazu heißt es auf der
webseite des max planck instituts für
astronomie pro sekunde strömen mehr als
zehn hoch 22 neutronen durch die fläche
von einem quadratzentimeter durch den
beta zerfall verwandeln sich einige der
angehäuften neutronen den photonen also
wasserstoff kern dabei werden jeweils
ein elektron und ein anti neutrino
abgegeben
die neutronen schließen sich also
schneller zu großen objekten zusammen
als der zerfall der neu entstandenen
konglomerate vonstatten geht so war aus
einzelnen neutronen können so schwere
elemente entstehen und das innerhalb von
sekundenbruchteilen die fachleute sind
extrem stolz auf ihre arbeit und das mit
recht denn dieser nachweis der letzten
element verbringt ist quasi das letzte
puzzlestück das noch in diesem großen
rätsel der physik fehlt dazu die
astrophysikerin camilla handeln die an
der studie beteiligt war
die ergebnisse dieser arbeit sind ein
wichtiger schritt bei der
entschlüsselung der nucleus synthese von
schweren elementen
und ihren kosmischen brutstätten dies
war nur durch die verknüpfung der jungen
disziplin der gravitationswellen
astronomie mit präziser spektroskopie
elektromagnetischer strahlung möglich
diese neuen messmethoden geben hoffnung
auf weitere bahnbrechende erkenntnisse
über die eigenschaften des r prozesses
die dunkle seite des universums
anklicken anschauen und hyperraum tv
abonnieren
neu in unserem wissenschafts netzwerkes
1054 und sehr cool also bis dann bleibt
dran